ach du heilige scheiße
bei leben ja ihr sehen richtig im titel
eingeblendet wir sind heute auf der
website von gucci und ich schau mal das
teuerste produkt ist ich habe
amerikanische videos gesehen wo leute
sich das günstigste produkt von louis
vitton oder canvas bestellt haben und
das war dann halt irgendwie socken oder
irgendwie so was wir schon heute
allerdings auf der website von gucci mal
was deren teuerstes produkt ist was
irgendwie im angebot haben um dann gucke
ich habe mir das gefällt und ob ich das
bestelle videos übrigens nicht
gesponsert
also ich das ist nicht wer auch zu schön
so sieht die webseite hier auf jeden
fall aus direkt wird geworben mit der
herbst winter 2018 kollektionen für
herren und damen wenn wir weiter runter
gehen sehen wir noch die spring summer
kollektive 2009 10
der das wird in drei tagen schon
vorgestellt ich dachte supermärkte
werden schon schlimm dass die jetzt
mitte september schon spekulatius darum
stehen haben aber die stellen in drei
tagen ihre neue sommerkollektion für
2009/10 vor dem sommer 2018 ist noch
nicht mal richtig vorbei wenn wir weiter
runter scrollen den wir hier
tragetaschen einen großen shopper mit
tigerkopf ihr könnt einfach mal kurz
gucken wie teuer der ist 2000 euro
wo ihr mich verarschen für solle
tragetasche ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
selbst feiere auch klamotten und ich
habe auch ein paar klamotten ein
bisschen teurer sind aber dass das sieht
doch nicht mehr schön aus ist natürlich
geschmackssache aber wär das schön finde
dadurch die kontrolle über sein leben
verloren das ist einfach aus wie so eine
königs tasche aus dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert oder so er wir werden etwas
ist dass die die eine bank überfallen
oder was also das ist der look 20 den
sie an hat hier so haben wir sehr genau
hier vorne
die sache ist er mich jetzt hier runter
gehe auf artikel die dabei sind da wird
hier einfach nicht diese komische dinge
ins angezeigt die auf dem kopf hat 1000
euro für eine verdammte branche
ich dachte die tasche vorhin für 1980
euro wer krass hier ist die gleiche
tasche in kag braun lacoste ihm nur 500
euro mehr also das ist schon wirklich
ein sehr gewagtes auto vor allem mit der
maske hatte
da sag ich nur ja das ist ja echt
absolute scheiße also ich weiß wirklich
nicht was ich gut schied am outfit denkt
aber naja wir erstmal weit war
das sieht aus die sonne wanderschuh wo
man als kind im zeltlager gesagt hat man
den brauch ich nicht er sieht einfach
nur scheiße aus 790 euro
dafür könnte man sich was weiß ich wie
viele paar richtig geile sneaker kaufen
wenn es leute feiern dann kauft euch das
ruhig das ist echt irre ich gehe einfach
nur die seite lang und will eigentlich
mir nur das teuerste produkt bestellen
und das video ist auch schon binnen 14
minuten und ich gehe ich bin ich bei
ansatzweise zu dem video thema bisher
gekommen allerdings würde ich sagen
meine lieben freunde kommen wieder jetzt
zu wie finde ich dann das teuerste
produkt also wir haben hier oben die
verschiedenen kategorien stories
brauchen wir glaube ich nicht geschenke
auch nicht dekor das vielleicht sogar
dekoration was teures dabei wenn ich ja
ganz logisch überlege sonst wetter sei
nicht ansatzweise so teuer wie ein
sessel oder so also dekoration step hier
vorne nur damit ihr wisst wie toll das
xs kostet hier alles so 550 euro das
sind einfach nur kerzen
das ist einfach eine kerze licht kann
ich auch günstiger kriegen das tolle ist
jetzt halt dass wir hier den preis
sortieren können von hoch bestätigt dass
auch klasse bei anderen webseiten steht
ja irgendwie zuerst preis niedrig bis
hoch falls man sich nicht so viel
leisten kann aber hier halt bei gucci
steht als erstes kommt sagte die
teuersten preis an ich möchte nicht dass
er mich da ist gerade irgendwie falsch
versteht oder so ich möchte überhaupt
nicht die marke gucci hätten ich selber
habe ehrlich gesagt auch einen sweater
von denen das ist auch der einzige aus
dem sortiment den ich eigentlich relativ
cool versteht halt nicht gut drauf oder
so sondern einfach ein cooles design
allerdings wie bereits gesagt habe ich
überhaupt nichts gegen diese marke es
ist einfach nicht ganz mein stil mich
feiert die designs einfach nicht so ich
weiß ich schreibe jetzt mal die
kommentare
ich mache mir jetzt schon einige sachen
wir sehen was haltet ihr davon was ist
vielleicht eure lieblings mag ich
schreibe gerne und in die kommentare
egal ob ihr jetzt sagt okay ich habe von
der marke zwar nichts weil es mir zu
teuer ist aber das ist meine absolute
lieblingsstadt weil ich es mega feier
und die spare darauf gerade schreiben
das gerne und in die kommentare
allerdings sind wir ja hier wegen
dekoration und das achte heilige scheiße
ach du heilige scheiße nein nein
27.000 euro für das ist laut o ich meine
wirklich leute ganz im ernst jeder kann
selbst für sich entscheiden ob er sich
halt ein paar avent aus drei flügeln aus
samt für die rund 20.000 euro bestellt
oder halt eine mercedes benz a klasse
limousine also entweder das hier so
einen schönen limousinen kleinwagen
brandneue a klasse ein pinkes hässliches
ausstellt
fick bei leben das war allerdings gerade
nur dekoration ich bin jetzt mal auf die
beauty seite hier gegangen also es gibt
dürfte sachen für nägel fürs gesicht für
die augen und die lippen wenn ich glaub
das wird nicht so toll wir gehen auch
schmuck und uhren
oh mein gott leute schmuck und uhren
wird heftig die kategorie schmuck und
uhren war unterteilt in mode schmuck
silber schmuck uhren und normal
schmuckem ich hab jetzt überall die
preis sortierung von preishoch bis
niedrig gemacht ich habe mir doch nicht
die preise angeguckt hier von den
teuersten produkten das machen wir jetzt
mal zusammen also bei mode schmuck ist
das hier das teuerste das heißt ich gehe
jetzt mal mit der maus drauf und mit
4500 euro für einen bh ich frag mal was
sie davon hält also jude wie teuer ist
so ein durchschnittlicher bh was ich das
jetzt 10 oder so 30 40 30 40 euro
okay was denkst wie vor ist der tollste
von gucci
das hier war allerdings nur der teuerste
bhd die hatten das heißt bei gucci
silberschmuck haben wir das teuerste für
3190 euro das hätte ich sogar dass es
endlich soweit dass es noch teurer ist
die teuerste gut figur kommt jetzt
allerdings doch
daher
vor dem preisen das
hast du eigentlich mit am teuersten ist
und dann haben wir hier bei schmuck das
teuerste 14.500
amoklauf
pocking bisher geht allerdings wirklich
nichts über den caravan tauss drei
flügeln aus samt 27.000 euro da muss man
echt ordentlichen stein im kopf haben
die gibt es auch noch kindersachen für
jungen für mädchen und für babys mal
schauen was das teuerste für babys ist
also preishoch bis niedrig für babys
1300 euro eine wickeltasche und das
tollste zum anziehen 690 euro ein baby
kleid menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßen sonst haben wir hier nur noch
watson newron den runway und dann kommt
auch schon zu damen und herren sachen
ich habe jetzt einfach mal
herrenkleidung alles gesamt komplettes
outfit hier ein gegeben als wir haben
hier hätten wir haben police wir haben
was auch immer das hier sein soll da ist
einfach ein verdammtes re drauf wir
haben ja noch komische hosen et cetera
pp das heißt ich klicke einfach mal
sortieren preishoch bis niedrig und
jetzt meine damen und herren kommen wir
zum teuersten produkt was ist komplett
herrenbekleidung bei gucci gibt also wir
haben hier alles noch mal sortiert die
tollsten sachen sind tatsächlich jacken
und das allerneuste verheerende 5800 ich
bin ganz ganz ganz ganz ehrlich mit euch
ich hätte gedacht dass es noch teurer
wäre als ich das gesehen habe da ist mir
direkt die kotze hochgekommen und dachte
okay dann ist die teuerste jacke
wahrscheinlich mit einem fünfstelligen
bereich allerdings haben wir hier noch
nicht bei den damen geschaut
hier sind auch krasse sachen also
kleider und so und auch sehr viel mit
leder und auch primärrecht jacken und so
das neueste produkte bei den damen ist
diese bomberjacke für 5980 mit
pailletten dran wie teuer wenn man die
männersache 5800
schauen wir uns die noch mal genauer an
die komische pinke frauen bomberjacke
hier würde ich ja eh nicht bestellen
also das hier ist nun also das teuerste
herrenbekleidung produkt bei gucci das
hier würde ich sagen schließlich sieben
20.000 euro das werde ich mir auf keinen
fall bestellen deshalb dieser typische
gute ton in diesem braun hier mit diesem
komischen teilen dran keine ahnung wie
man das nennt was mit dem sonst so für
bilder der typ dann hinten steht
natürlich ganz fett gut ja auch drauf es
ist halt ganz ehrlich gesagt ist teil
den er zwar so tragen kann den ich aber
niemals an mir so sehen wollen würde ich
meine solche braunen schüchen sonne hose
die unten weiter ist als oben und dann
so eine jacke die komplett zu ist ist
sehr eigenartig und schied der parteien
jacke aus canvas mit mit diesem coup
dingen keine ahnung größe l ist
verfügbar für 5800 euro
leute ihr trifft entscheiden ob ich mir
diese jacke bestellen sollen denn falls
wir diesem video hier 100000 daumen hoch
schaffen sollte werde ich mir
tatsächlich diese jacke für 5800 euro
bestellen anprobieren und dazu dann in
einigen tagen oder in einer woche keine
ahnung wann die dann genau an kommen
wird ein neues video zu hoch laden
natürlich mit an boxing g cetera pp
also wenn ihr das wollt leute
hunderttausend likes lasten like dabei
diesem video wenn ihr unbedingt wollte
dass ich mir das teuerste herren produkt
auf ganz gut ski bestelle die bereits
allerdings beginnen gesagt ich will
überhaupt nicht gut sie hätten wir
überhaupt nicht sagen hey das ist so
ekelhaft das ist die halbe hauptmann
stil und die zmp ich mache die klamotten
persönlich einfach nicht so gern ich
könnte mir nicht selbst mir vorstelle
ich meine ich trank mir sowas so
irgendwas schlichtes wieder haben
übrigens gefragt ob das ihr im shop
kommt wollt ihr dass das in shop kommt
es halt so ein oberst wetter mit einem
etwas anderen schnitt hier unten relativ
locker fällt ja wir haben hier so ein
smiley logo eingestickt mit so ein paar
zur laufenden bunten farbtupfern wenn
ihr bock habt dass der im ersten zwölf
den shop kommen soll dann schreib mir
die kommentare ob ihr das wollt
hey ich bin luca allerdings würde ich an
dieser stelle das heutige wieder zoff
beenden meine damen und herren ich fand
es auf jeden fall mega mega krass zu
sehen was es auf gucci auf der website
alles für komische produkte gibt ich
meine das wirklich einen dekorations
abteilung things d 72
also auto ich könnte kotzen mir gesagt
wenn ihr wollt dass ich mir diese
komische braune lederjacke bestelle dann
lassen leichter freunde und dann sehen
wir uns eventuell in ein paar tagen
wieder wo ich diese jacke an probieren
würde
[Musik]